[Musik]
wir testen heute von canyon das scale up
scale ist ein kreml bike wandel bedeutet
es ich möchte beides können möchte auf
der straße gut zurechtkommen und auch im
gelände und das probieren wir jetzt mal
aus
[Musik]
ja das klärt sich im gelände sehr
angenehm nach meinem ersten eindruck
bietet es ist wirklich federungskomfort
es geht mühelos über das wurzelwerk über
stock und stein
das liegt an dem besonders konstruierten
lenker kenny nennt das den hub der im
oberen teil ein flex bereich hat und
dieser flex bereich ermöglicht die
federung der restliche lenker ist ein
typischer rennrad lenker der auf der
straße die stabilität gewährleisten soll
und das werden wir jetzt ausprobieren
[Musik]
so das war die straßen fahrt es ist
schon erstaunlich weil im gelände war
das rad ja sehr bequem zu fahren ist gut
über die hindernisse hinweg gerollt und
auf der straße dann tatsächlich das
phänomen das fahrrad bleibt eine hohe
laufruhe es fährt sehr sicher durch die
kurven auch bei hoher geschwindigkeit
und die geschwindigkeit ist tatsächlich
mit der auf dem rennrad annähernd
vergleichbar
dazu tragen hat mir viel greifen bei die
canon mit schwalbe gemeinsam entwickelt
hat die sich auf der lauffläche so
entwickelt dass sie wenig rollwiderstand
briten auf dem asphalt und an den seiten
das gelände dann doch mehr grip so dass
es also eine gute kombination ist auf
der einen seite auf dem asphalt schnell
und im gelände griffig insgesamt würde
ich sagen ist das rad eine gelungene
kombination aus rennrad und
geländetauglichen fahrrad wer sich
diesen spaß gönnen will muss 4600 euro
bezahlen zumindest für die ausstattung
die ich hier jetzt im moment getestet
habe das muss man sich leisten wollen
wer dazu bereit ist dem ist fahrspaß
garantiert
[Musik]